former Trump propagandist Steve Bannon
who has also been an antagonist of mine
has been subpoenaed by special counsel
Jack Smith will Bannon show up is the
question Bannon has been willing in the
past to be held in contempt is Bannon
potentially a linchpin in potentially
forthcoming federal charges against
Trump we just don't know Mark Meadows
did sit down with the special counsel
Jack Smith Trump has made a big deal out
of arguing that this Jack Smith guy is
compromised we don't even know his real
name and all sorts of crazy things but
so far I have to say I'm not like a
particular fan of special counsels what
I mean by that is you could be a special
counsel and do a good job or not a good
job have leaks or not have leaks Etc
Jack Smith has done a really good job of
preventing leaks not speaking out of
turn not getting ahead of himself